um while I was in the marriage and for
years I've been just insecure didn't
like my the sound of my voice didn't
like what I looked like didn't like
anything about myself and then when I
got married the person just really
watered that seed of of my own
self-doubt and my own insecurity and
made it worse yes and um I Heard um tdj
said and he said um what you say about
yourself
and how you think about yourself is way
more important and effective than what
anybody else can say or think about you
so if you yes if you speak positively
over yourself and that's what I started
doing so my first my first big
confession was the album I put out
called good morning gorgeous I didn't
believe I was gorgeous ever but I had to
say something I didn't believe you know
that was bigger than me and then it
began to manifest in my heart my heart
is gorgeous my my mind is gorgeous I'm a
beautiful person you know I'm so so you
have to believe that about yourself